d'autant qu'on accueille et oui c'est sa
dernière aujourd'hui il veut nous dire
au revoir c'est jérémy ferrari la
tradition
ralala quel honneur d'amour ça va bon
alors là ça y est ça y est ça et là on
va pas on va pas tourner autour du pont
c'est pourquoi je suis là vous en avez
parler pas mal dans l'émission la presse
aussi on a on a pas mal parlé allons
droit au but
ah ouais je sais gérer mieux si nelson
mandela est mort non d'accord oui ça va
pas là je pars je vous quitte mais je
m'en vais je sais que vous avez engagé
florent peyre comme quoi dans cette
émission on est vite remplacé a rien à
voir
le prends pas mal il est très drôle
c'est un ami à moi vous avez fait un
très bon choix
florent je te laisse donc cette petite
ménagerie thé préparé un petit mémo que
tu m'aimes gré sur ton frigo la manière
dont il faut s'occuper chacun tu sais
chaque chroniqueur est différent ils ont
chacun leur chronique euris leurs
caractères ils se nourrissent tous deux
choses différentes
tout d'abord prend bien soin de ma
petite valoches c'est celle qui me
manquera le plus oh ce n'est pas la plus
belle n'est pas celle qui allait le plus
vif ni le poids le plus soyeux 1 mais
elle est très affectueuse caresser qu'il
ne lui reste que ça n est plus tout
jeune et la maladie commence à la gagner
elle a le train arrière totalement
paralysé elle est déjà aveugle d'un oeil
gauche
le vétérinaire est tout de même confiant
car malgré la maladie elle se nourrit et
continue de grossir
il n'y aura cependant pas de miracle et
ce sera très certainement son dernier
noël si elle pleure pendant la nuit il
faut lui mettre patauge dans son panier
il est employé mais ne s'en est pas
encore aperçu il a également conseillé
de castres et au plus vite jean michel
maire sa tâche sera donc mise aux
enchères mardi
les bénéfices seront entièrement
reversés à une association de lutte
contre la déforestation une bille d'or
une tête coupée un arbre planté par
content qu'il ait castries il n'est pas
castries il ne faut pas le mettre dans
la même loge kenora elle est en pleine
chaleur et ce depuis 33 ans
il fait également toujours museler
thierry moreau sinon il fait des blagues
tout à l'heure il m'a attrapée dans le
couloir il m'en a fait une
qu'est ce que c'est un roux sur un
scooter à trois roues oui drôle lui et
pour ça je vous quitte je recommence ce
genre de blagues abate le surveiller
également bien le petit jean luc c'est
celui qui a le plus fort caractère parce
que c'est un croisé moitié breton moitié
pékinois il est très intelligent c'est
toujours les petits matins les plus
intelligents j'essaie de le faire se
reproduire avec eric le chauffeur de
salle
on nous donnait une nouvelle espèce un
chinois noir un chinois he en fait une
espèce qui est une toute petite
claquette mais qui court très très bien
je comprends pas ce qu'on passe si vite
que ça a fait recours il faut également
surveiller très très très de très très
près bertrand chamerois à fort de
l'appeler moustache il l'a mal pris il a
totalement pété les plombs
j'ai certainement évidemment oublié de
citer quelques personnes notamment
christophe carrière je sais que c était
son préféré
j'aurais tellement aimé te dire que
c'était réciproque j'oublie quelques
personnes camille combal philippe vandel
isabelle morini-bosc gilles verdez
évidemment plein d'autres gens mais ne
soyez pas vexer si je ne vous ai pas
cités dans cette chronique c'est que
vraiment je m'en fous alors pas de
regrets
quelqu'un quand même oui notamment cyril
oui je vous ai pas oubliés
voyez série là si on est très très
proche de plus en plus et c'est pour ça
que je vais devoir rejoindre laurent
ruquier parce que j'aime pas trop les
[ __ ]
bravo bref voilà j'ai un ami je reviens
nous voir ici temps tu veux rappeler
c'est chez toi même sa chatte hold up si
tu veux ou tu veux médaille je la donne
non ouvrage ne peux pas c'est trop cher
mais voilà des gens vraiment